president of the bundesrat
and lower houses of parliament
colleagues from the state assemblies
excellencies state now ladies and
gentlemen I want to thank these young
people very much for the words here in
the chapel where it used to be the
Church of reconciliation
your words are food for thought this is
also true from the young people we heard
from the bishop Guard States earlier
they remind us of what happened here but
first and foremost and this came across
in the speeches of each and every one of
them what it means for the future and
what we must take to heart and do for
the future since 1960 when the Berlin
Wall was built the Church of
reconciliation was in the border strip
neither East Berliners nor West
Berliners could visit it and in 85 it
was demolished and this was so wrong
because the individual citizens were
targeted and yet they were only seeking
liberty by demolishing the Church of
reconciliation we saw how the
dictatorship of East Germany could not
be reconciled with the individual needs
of its citizens for liberty
too many people were victims of the East
German regime and we have not forgotten
these people I remember those who were
killed at theirs Berlin Wall because
they were seeking Liberty I remember
these 75,000 people who were arrested
and imprisoned because they were fleeing
East Germany I remember all of those who
suffered repression because their family
members had fled I remember those who
were under surveillance who had
enunciated those who were oppressed
their dreams and hopes were killed
because they did not want to subject
themselves to stay
our betweenness the 9th of November is a
terrible day for German history on this
day we also remember the victims of the
Nazis programs in the ninth of November
1938 we remember from the 9th to the
10th of November 1938 the crimes that
were committed against Jews in Germany
and the result of this was the show the
9th of November in which both both the
most awful and the most wonderful
moments of our history took place remind
us that hatred racism and anti-semitism
must be stopped wherever we encounter
them it admonishes us this day to do all
we can to protect human dignity the rule
of law freedom because 30 years ago on
this date the Berlin Wall opened and
then fell just before that no one would
have believed it even possible at the
start of 1989 it was a small minority
fighting for civil rights and democracy
suffering discrimination persecution and
incarceration as a result but this
minority managed to encourage thousands
and hundreds of thousands in autumn of
1989 who took to the streets to protest
others went via Hungary Prague or Warsaw
and turned their backs on these Germany
all of them contributed to bringing down
the Berlin Wall opening the way to
democracy in our country and all of them
do gratitude the peaceful revolution was
inspired by solid Arnage which led to
democratic successes in the Czech
Republic the charter 77 encouraged this
in the Baltic States the longest human
chain in history pushed for independence
in in Hungary the Iron Curtain was made
permeable the call for
and created new democracies in Eastern
Europe and Central Europe Germany and
Europe could finally grow back together
but the values on which Europe is built
freedom democracy equality and the rule
of law preservation of human rights they
are anything but something we can take
for granted again and again we must live
them we must defend them and in the
future too Europe must fight for human
rights and tolerance for freedom and
democracy and this in times of sweeping
technological and global changes this is
more pressing matter before the
contribution of the individual may
sometimes seem small but we mustn't
become discouraged because of this
instead we must remember the struffolis
words who said that freedom is like the
sea he said the individual waves may not
seem to do much but the power of the
tide is impossible to resist Berlin Wall
is now relegated to the Animas of
history and now we want to ensure that
no wall separate people again it proves
to us that no wall is so high and so
strong that we cannot break it I not
concern spoke at home about the wall he
said when we created the wall we
couldn't imagine how high it was inside
us we got used to its horizons we got
used to its wind shadow and in its wind
shadow we cast no shadows now we stand
naked of any excuse and this is true for
all of us in the east and in the West we
are naked of any excuse and it is down
to us to do what we can for freedom and
democracy thank you
[Applause]